so it would seem that it started from
the inside of the structure
investigators will be able to determine
you know there were no kitchen crews or
anyone getting ready for the day
anything like that prep work anything in
the building at 4 45 a.m there was
nobody here and you said employees left
p.m sir yes sir 9pm last night
what's your message to the residents
also the people of las vegas
who want to come up here and check it
out like what's your message to them
because you guys are still you know i
right so we're currently blocking the
road
down by the lower lodge
and the reason being is because we want
to make sure that we have plenty of fire
access for fire crews investigators etc
so
currently we're not going to allow
anybody to come up the canyon i don't
know how long that's going to last but
we would certainly advise not to come up
here
at least for the next couple of days
while we get this figured out you know
we don't as everybody knows the road up
it's one way in and one way out and so
if they were if there were a lot of
people coming up here to be spectators
that would cause problem for fire crews
that are that are interchanging
there's a there's a fireplace in the
center of the dining room do we know um
any chance of what kind of fireplace was
it like burning wood gas anything like
that that you know used to for the
center of the dining room
i'm going to speculate that it's a wood
burning fireplace based on my experience
in the lodge in the past i've come up
here before and had hot chocolate and
sat by the fire many times you know so
i can't tell you if they were using it
you know i
seems highly unlikely considering how
hot it's been for all of us lately you
know i mean we've had record heat in the
last week you know so i i can't i can't
say that they were they were they
weren't using it but i would call it
highly unlikely how fortunate are we to
make sure that this card is
as i mentioned
as crews began arriving on scene we
immediately set up a defensive posture
to protect the surrounding area so when
you when you declare it uh fire
defensive that means we're gonna defend
everything around it and we're going to
sacrifice the structure that's that's
burning
crews made the immediate decision that
there was no way they were going to save
any portion of the structure and
therefore they began setting up all
their lines you know in that defensive
posture water supply up here is not near
as good as
it is in las vegas there are only a few
hydrants in the area
some of which are i'm being told
supplied by water tanks
water supply was never an issue but we
don't necessarily have as much pressure
as we do
and volume as we do in las vegas so we
had to be very smart and tactical about
where we placed our defensive lines
to make sure we weren't wasting the
water that we did have and that we were
putting it in the right position to
protect not only the timber but the
surrounding structures
from
radiant heat
and also any you know embers that were
coming down as a result of the fire you
know so we're
i think they did a fantastic job of
preventing you know the the fire from
spreading to not only the timber but the
surrounding structures i'm being told
that the
the lodges there's approximately i think
20 lodges or so
that people can come in and stay at
the
occupants of those lodges were not
evacuated they were told to shelter in
place which means that firefighters felt
they had a pretty good position between
the lodge and you know the
living quarters
which were they're not attached they're
detached small cabins
in the in the near vicinity